foreign
back to Florida what's up Nicole
Hi how are you partying what are you up
to
oh nothing just hanging out with my
five-month-old here
yeah you know it's it's a good life the
good life well played well played what's
up
um okay so my question is how do my
husband and I best raise our sons to not
latch on to uh like OCD Tendencies when
I've been diagnosed with OCD and I also
have anxiety welcome to the gang dude
yeah all righty isn't it what a fun Club
to be a part of right yeah
um okay so how old are your kids you
have five month old and what else I got
five month old and an almost
two-year-old and I've been noticing with
the two-year-old that he is already so
uh my OCD is it's been called
religiosity or scrupulosity
um so it feels much more with like
um in my thoughts and my speech rather
than like organizing and stuff like that
yeah
um hold on when you get really really
really tired
yeah what's the physical manifestation
um
sometimes it's
and I think it's I grew up in a pretty
um
I mean fairly religious Mennonite
um house and so it's I think it's based
around
worrying that I'm gonna sin and go to
hell like that's the
you know I mean I don't think about that
that's kind of a big consequence right
well yeah it is you know rather
life-changing yeah some people don't
want to get in car wrecks right so they
don't drive or they don't leave their
house you just don't want to be tortured
for eternity right exactly Fair exactly
fair to your poor sweet little body
trying to trying to absorb that yeah so
like it it
and like fear of judgment
let me ask you a scary thing yeah what
does that guilt get you
because it gives you something what does
it give you
I don't know I don't know if it's a way
to just not deal with what I'm actually
feeling
look at you dude have you been to
counseling before
oh like four different counselors all
right good
um yeah well played so you've you've put
some work in already I could tell
um yeah yeah so it's a good way for your
brain to distract you from reality
uh so what's the reality you need
distracted from
[Music]
that you're beautiful
that you're a great wife
that you're a fun friend that you're a
good mom
because you don't feel comfortable when
I say those things do you
why can't you hear that
I can hear it I just think
um it's hard for me to say out loud to
others like I feel like it's immodest
there you go
and so do you realize that your core
sensor is that this whole thing that
this whole body that you inhabit is
wrong
that it's broken you have to just your
body is distracting you from you
and that is a recipe for hell on Earth
and I'm sorry that your other counselors
didn't tell you that
but do me a favor put your hand like
open up your hand and put it
um just below your neck on your chest
okay
say the words out loud
I love this girl
is that easy to do is that hard
are you just performing for the show
it was awkward
I want you to do that 10 times a day in
front of the mirror
here's what you have to make peace with
you have to make peace with you
and I know you called about your
daughter we'll get to your your
daughter's son we'll get to your kid
but I live this life that you're talking
about
and it's when I realized that my body
was trying to protect me from what was
going on
and it was sending me signals and so OCD
wasn't a thing to run from it wasn't a
thing to be terrified from and by the
way I have to say say it up front mine's
not debilitating mine's frustrating and
annoying but it's not debilitating like
I don't yeah mine's not either I don't
wash my hands till I bleed or anything
like that
um
but I do have to make a bunch of laps
around the house in the evening to make
sure the doors are locked and I do count
I do blink and I I got all my all the
stuff that's fine
here's the deal it's my body trying to
get my attention almost always okay
that's number one so I don't want you to
give up on Nicole
it is not immodest
in fact as far as I'm concerned it is
honoring
the person God created
to tell the truth about yourself
and if you're beautiful and you're a
good mom and you're a great wife not
perfect none of us are
it's dishonest to not say that do not
live into that
okay
and I know that takes work especially
when you've been told by everybody you
know and love and care about that that's
wrong
and that will get you towards your worst
fear which is burning in Hell For
Eternity right
that's number one number two I'm gonna
be careful about because I don't want to
put my kids stuff out there too much but
I will say I sat down with one of my
kids just about a year ago
and here's the conversation I had
I have a very special brain
and my brain pays very close attention
to certain things and it is very good at
reading a room
and because it's good at reading a room
I can I I can make people feel
comfortable
and give them some peace I can also make
people feel very uncomfortable because
then I'm not when I'm not paying
attention right
and I told one of my kids you have that
same special brain
and
it's a gift and it's just something that
makes us different and we have to work
through some things that other people
don't have to work through
and that phrase special brain
because one of my kids was counting a
lot and asked my wife to turn the radio
down because
they were trying to Blink between every
drum beat and they couldn't keep up and
my wife just was like oh good my husband
created another one of him and
um and at the same time I would submit
that it's been a superpower it's really
frustrating to work with me sometimes
right and I think it can be fun too
right so all that to say is this that
phrase special brain
and the phrase I have it too
and the phrase
and so we have some extra work to do
those are your three magic points
okay okay number one there is a genetic
in a neurological basis for OCD period
it just is
and
genes are most often expressed
environmentally something in the world
that they're growing up in sets them off
like a light switch right
and so if you have parents with OCD you
have parents with ADHD you're probably
gonna have kids with ADHD or you're not
probably you're going to be
statistically more likely to
one because there's a genetic component
and two you've created a household that
has chaos in it right and that's your
body's response to it so
the second thing is is you're gonna let
your kid know you're not alone I'm with
you and there's something about social
norming especially with kids letting
them know you're not crazy you're just
like me and right now you don't believe
it but you're the most important person
in the whole wide world to this little
kid
mm-hmm and in a weird way they get to be
like Mommy
and the third thing is is it's a context
not an excuse the world will not Bend to
us
so
when I need to check the locks three
times before I leave my house or five
times or however many times I need to do
it
I gotta get up earlier because my work
starts at eight o'clock
right the world doesn't Bend to me
you can ask Kelly she does not Bend when
I'm late right
so all to say is you're going to
communicate to your kid this isn't a
free pass on the world
right you got some extra work to do
right
but I don't want you
and it's gonna be hard I don't want you
trying to fix her
him him okay
well so
okay I have a couple questions bring
them
okay well he's only two so at what point
do I have that conversation with him
what's an age-appropriate
what what behaviors is he already
exhibiting okay well that was my other
question I'm on you know okay well so
I'm a warrior so I'm constantly like oh
he's dying of cancer or oh he's gonna
and so I'm obviously gonna be like oh he
has OCD already look at that so I don't
know if I'm over concerned or yes yes
yes
um yes so like he's been he'll do stuff
like um closing the doors and and all
none of these things are every time it's
not like every time he sees a door open
he has to close it but he'll for someone
his age it feels a little peculiar to me
like he'll close doors have you ever
been around two-year-olds before
uh a little bit not a ton okay you don't
really know what peculiar is your kids I
I'd be willing to bet your kid's great
oh no he is great I know he's great he's
fantastic I just don't know if the
behavior is
I don't know if if normal is a word for
a two-year-old I mean there's there's
some way outside of the bell curve stuff
and I also think as a culture we've
gotten so obsessed with these norming
things that were we've made our kids who
are special in and of themselves
like every kid has like a thing
right and right well and he like he'll
he'll push our chairs in when we're done
with dinner and he'll he he will like
put his toys away which I'm not
complaining about that is not that's not
that's not that's not a pathology
fantastic but like some people see it
and they're like did you tell him to do
that no call don't put that into the
world it doesn't need to be there
all right you're a good mom you're
raising a good healthy kid
and let me say this here's a trap I
don't want you to fall in please please
please please don't Google diagnose your
kid
okay don't you're gonna make yourself
crazy and you're gonna put you're gonna
give that burden to your kid to Carrie
it's not it's not fair
if you have some legitimate concerns
about your kids psychiatric well-being
or their pediatric well-being great
every parent does
that's what trained medical
professionals are for
do not make a diagnosis about your kid
okay and in fact you may want to go get
re-diagnosed with OCD and see if that
still even holds true
when he so when he does stuff like this
like pushing chairs and cleaning his
toys up like doing stuff like that I
love to encourage him to do that but I
guess I'm wondering am I
encouraging an OCD tenancy or should I
just
Nicole yeah he's cleaning he's cleaning
up after himself I know he's pushing in
chairs because it's fun
he's accomplishing things he's moving
his body he's pushing up against
resistance and it's moving under his
weight feels good
okay he's picking up his toys probably
because he saw his OCD mom picking up
everything in her life too
like like there's not what you're
telling me not one single thing
if
he was in bed
screaming his lungs out
because there was a stuffed animal out
of place
and it was chaotic and snot coming out
of his nose until he got up and moved
the arm just right and then got back
into bed then I would say you probably
need to go talk to somebody
like he's clearly projecting something
out but again he's freaking two he's two
sounds like you got a lovely little kid
who's cleaning up there's just moms All
Over America listening to this going
what
cleans up his toys that's awesome
my son I don't know how this happened my
son will walk in and be like I'm tired
I'm going to bed so I'll feel good
tomorrow
I don't know where he got that from
but he doesn't need to go see somebody
it's just amazing behavior that I'm
really oh I'm encouraged I was like
ready to go man I'm glad you honor your
body better than your dad does because
your dad's like I'm tired
I bet I could uh
drink some coffee and stay up later
whatever
then your kids are good
I think the work that needs to be done
here Nicole let's start with let's start
with Nicole
and I think it would be time to go get
re reevaluated okay and sit down with a
psychologist or sit down with a
counselor and say I'm ready to confront
my OCD head-on
and there's some behavioral techniques
there's some therapeutic techniques that
are showing incredible efficacy there's
even some medication that's showing some
incredible incredible efficacy
but I think it's time to tackle it head
on and what we're going to create is
some peace in your house I'm missing you
building a non-anxious life too
um
oftentimes especially with thought OCD
thought OCD and anxiety really co-mingle
a lot and um takes a pretty
sophisticated practitioner to parse them
apart
um
but I'm going to send you a copy of this
book too because I want you to check it
out you and your husband can read it and
um I think it might be good to work
through because I think backing out 30
000 feet and handling some of these
peripheral things might um be a gift to
you in the Long Haul and maybe turn some
of these alarms down
again if your kid does some things that
are
really truly worry you
or as importantly a couple of moms in
your circle that you trust that say hey
is this normal behavior like yeah it's
fine
um please please take your kid to go see
a psychiatrist or go see a child
counselor or doctor ASAP ASAP
but if your kids clean up his toys
pushing pushing the chair in good for
him it's amazing
it's amazing and I'll say it again
you're a good mom Nicole
you're a good mom